les terriens de ce soir sont thierry
marx
alors thierry avant de commencer soyons
clairs vous êtes le chef chauffe de top
chef sur m6 à ne pas confondre avec
frédéric anton le chef chauffe de
masterchef sur tf1
mais alors chauffe c'est pour que les
cheveux tombent pas dans la soupe non
non ça a été une de mes particularités
très tôt hélas l'émission s'appelle
salue les canards et le groupe est
vraiment devant
[Musique]
thierry marx quoi bon soir vous êtes
l'un des grands noms de la cuisine
française actuelle adulé par des
millions de gens qui ne goûteront
pourtant jamais votre cuisine si c'est
un peu comme si on adorait un musicien
sans avoir entendu sa musique finalement
je reçois beaucoup pourtant ouais c'est
compliqué il vous aime sans vous goûtez
j'ai toujours que j'ai une sale gueule
mais finalement j'ai peut-être une bonne
gueule tout de suite et
[Applaudissements]
on n'est pas le terme de gastronomie
vous avez déclaré ce mot me dégoûte je
vois un gros gastéropodes baveux qui se
traîne je sois pas que le mot convenait
viard culinaire est bien plus jolie tout
d'amour alors vous n'aimez pas non plus
qu'on vous parle de cuisine moléculaire
vous avez déclaré c'est un mot qui
résonne comme nucléaire c'est vrai même
temps c'est un pléonasme la cuisine
moléculaire le fait à sa gt de l'eau
c'est des molécules entre elles et en
même temps c'était une porte
d'observation de la cuisine que j'ai
pris pour essayer de m'instruire un peu
plus et transformer l'épreuve et
produits autrement que ce qui était fait
par mes et je complète de la cuisine
high tech
c'est pas faux c'est vrai c'est pas faux
seins vers la modernité vous avez un
laboratoire le foodlab alors avec un
enseignant chercheur qui s'appelle
raphaël haumont vous utilisez les
thermoplongeur les les centrifugeuses la
cryoextraction les ultrasons les hautes
pressions quand on parlait second de
cuisine moléculaire mais attention ils
utilisent des produits on connaît pas
bien ça fait changer tout ça ça faisait
un peu chimiques alors que pas du tout
au contraire on essaie de mieux
comprendre l'ingrédient pour le
transformer un petit peu différemment
sinon couple et on continue à couper
comme coupé audi c'est un psychologue
mais pour les tomates s'est passé
vous travaillez sur l'encapsulage des
saveurs au coeur d'une membrane d'eau
minérale sur le déçu crash des desserts
sur la lyophilisation des alcools la
lyophilisation d alcool par exemple ça
vous permet de rajouter un très très bon
goût naturel de rome dans un bisse cuite
sans avoir à ajouter de sucre donc c'est
toujours un apport pour le plaisir alors
est publié à quelques temps chez
flammarion avait comme on le répertoire
de la cuisine innovante qui parle de
tout ça et autres écrits vous signé la
préface de l'entrepreneur et l'inde
signé chez ellipses vous dit toute ma
vie j'ai refusé la résignation et l'aveu
d'impuissance qui se dessine en
filigrane derrière l'indignation
c'est vrai je crois qu'un monde il faut
s'anime et on te faut réagir et passer à
l'action c'est ce que vous avez fait on
passe à l'interview portrait
[Musique]
or thierry masson rabon soir êtes né le
19 septembre 1962 à ménilmontant dans le
20e arrondissement
issu d'une famille juive immigrés
d'europe de l'est votre grand père
marcel était né à varsovie militant
communiste
résistants de choc c'est lui qui vous
élève avec votre grand mère francine car
vos parents sont trop pauvres pour vous
loger dans cete c'est plutôt de bons
souvenirs c'est alors c'est marcel votre
grand-père qui vous dit si tu veux être
un homme libre tu dois savoir
oui on va perdre j'ai toujours regardé
région de savoir donc ils ont le pouvoir
ouais d'eau qui avait de cesse tous les
matins de venir à l'école il faut que tu
apprennes et pourtant ça rentrait pas
mais c'est vrai qu'à l'école déplacé
d'office au fond de la classe avec ceux
de la cité du 140 rue de ménilmontant
ça arrange pas les choses quoi alors ça
s'était toujours l'étiquetage
il n'y a que nous qui ne pouvons pas
réussir et qui rêve forcément vers le
monde du travail plutôt l'ouvrier fall
type qu'on montre un peu du doigt alors
ce qu'il vous plaît en fait à l'époque
c'est accompagner votre grand père
marcel sur les marchés le dimanche
lui il vend l'huma l'huma dimanche et
vous kiffe les chiens ce qui était
intéressant dont ce parti communiste de
cette époque c'était une vraie
fraternité de noël par contre dans la
cité c'était quand même des types qui
était capable de descendre pour dire à
temps et la police c'est nous qui
l'avons la sphère les voyous d'accoler
vous cassez vous faites pas chier et ils
organisaient le ensemble de trucs au
niveau du sport c'était un parti
communiste près du monde ouvrier et
c'était encore le militantisme dans les
bistrots c'était un type qui aller
prêcher la bonne parole dans les
bistrots et votre grand père il ya aussi
l'autre grand oncle avant lui qui est
très marrant parce que il avait un chien
et il a accroché ses médailles de guerre
au collier du chien voyez était
anarchiste
ouais bah ouais c'était une famille
étonnante l'une de relief qui était
toujours prêt à en découdre en même
temps et beaucoup de beaucoup de
discrétion si une faille très discrètes
aux 140 une vie de quartier ce qui
n'existe plus maintenant aussi la
méluche ya pas un type qui pouvait
mourir 140 soit qui est une quête ouais
kate on mettait un catafalque tout le
monde file et s'emballe c'était un truc
c'était fort alors de cette époque date
votre passion jamais oublier pour les
arts martiaux et le japon en allant voir
un film en fait c'est une connerie je
rentre au cinéma détour elle porte des
lilas et je pense voir un film de bruce
lee ouais et c'était le fils de ouaga
qui la trilogie samouraï l'histoire de
miyamoto musashi un film de trois heures
savim initiatique où un type à sale type
finalement qui est un espèce de type ba
garze va être éduqué par un moine et à
venir le plus grand sabreurs japonais
miyamoto musashi avec une ligne de
conduite incroyable et le japon nous a
jamais quittés ou genève est ceinture
noire de judo verrait passer du temps au
japon ce que j'aime au japon surtout
c'est celle ce côté il n'y a pas de
conflit entre la tradition et innovation
à ce sens civique des japonais alors
j'avais 13 ans quand la deux mondes qui
a été faite de logement social par la
famille est acceptée vous déménagez à
champigny dans le val-de-marne
voilà vous dites une adolescence dans
les cages d'escalier des terrains vagues
je viens du quart monde vous dit ac
c'est la fracture parce que on se
retrouve dans une cité ce qu'on appelle
les bars dans les bars comme ça les
barres de logement et pas de rapport au
travail par otor a mis le montant on
avait un rapport au travail avec
l'artisanat les petits boulots monter
démonter le marché gagner quatre sous là
rien il ya un énorme hypermarchés tout
un peu la caverne d'ali baba pour aller
faucher 3,4 connerie mais rien et on
passe notre temps à à défier la cité des
bois l'abbé par rapport à l'agenda des
boullereaux enfin la castagne quoi c'est
alors évidemment quand vous dites que
voulait faire l'école hôtelière le
conseiller d'orientation vous dit pour
toi ce sera assez ap mécanique générale
il ya une phrase qui m'a traîné dans la
tête vers des années c'est pas pour des
gens comme vous ouais je n'arrêtais pas
de dire mes parents il bosse comme
disent non mon père a fait mon père
aussi il ya une espèce de genre il y
avait défendu ces deux républiques
françaises et cette dame dit c'est pas
pour dire mais c'est quoi des gens comme
moi là vous quittez la maison et vous
mettez un petit peu à faire des
conneries vous terminerez en garde à vue
oui bah les conneries de ce quartier là
c'était la castagne couet
c'étaient les mauvais coups heureusement
le grand père marcel vient vous chercher
par le col et une semaine plus tard de
cet apprenti pâtissier chez les
compagnons du devoir ce qui sera pour
vous une école formidable c'est des gens
qui ont des valeurs id altérables de
fraternité puis je me souviens de la
première parole de ce qu'on appelle un
premier en ville de chez les compagnons
il m'a dit tu sais on et la noblesse de
l'ouvrier et tout de suite ça a fait
écho dans la tête il est toujours on
doit être dans la vérité donc on peut on
se raconte pas de conneries 6 et puis
finalement ces gens n'ont remis un cadre
éducationnel à ma vie professionnelle
trois ans plus tard vous décrochez votre
cap2 pâtissier mais vous vous engager
dans l'armée comme parachutiste
d'infanterie de marine et vous vous
retrouvez casques bleus au liban et vous
finirez dans les phalangistes du camp
chrétien avec le général aoun vous
allaitez phalangistes on a soutenu une
cause chrétienne où ils en sont sans lui
semblait que cet endroit jamais vous
avez 19 ans quoi donc
presque n'importe quelle aventure
surtout que c'est le charisme d autres
des fois qu'ils - qui vous impressionne
et vous croyez des combats justes et
finalement sur le terrain
je crois qu'il ya peut-être des guerres
justes médias pas de guerre propre
lorsque vous découvrez à beyrouth c'est
que malgré la guerre il ya des trêves
durant lesquelles les factions viennent
s'approvisionner enfin la fal et vous
découvrez qu'en fait nourrir les gens
c'est au cube unique celle échange la
confiance qui naît chez l'autre quand
vous le nourrissez ya un instant de paix
là vous accepter que quelqu'un
nourrissent votre intimité moi je me
souviens toujours de ce moment où tout
le monde se gaieté ça avait été le
quartier était pourri et il ya un titre
qui faisait des falafels et du pain puis
sur une plaque de métal c'est forcément
pas le meilleur falafel que j'ai mangé
de ma vie mais toucher le pain chaud la
sauce blanche leleu le falafel écrasé
devant avec un peu d'oignons
et ça aussi c'est resté plus tard je les
décoder plus d'argent que ce que je
raconte la facilement à 50 ans il a émis
un certain nombre d'années elle décoder
alors on retour du liban vous êtes dit
vous en morceaux et là vous vous
reconstruisez autour de la cuisine
voyager d'abord beaucoup ensuite vous
commencez en province jusqu'au mandarin
oriental à paris dernière question
thierry marx est plutôt tendance car
oubrou chaud j'ai beaucoup de mal à
répondre il ya par boutade je dirais
gauche oh bien sûr l'est mais pour moi
marx a quand même été un clinicien du
capitaliste voile important alors je
revis dire les deux mon capitaine avait
très bien
[Applaudissements]
on passe maintenant le dossier de la
semaine avec les vitaux de blacko et
c'est la journaliste gastronomique
elvira masson que nous retrouverons sur
ce plateau après le magnéto
la france a toujours été un pays de la
bonne bouffe et là on frôle
l'indigestion une dizaine d'émissions de
cuisine à la télé chaque semaine une
quarantaine de magazines en kiosque
chaque mois sans oublier les 1800
bouquin publié chaque année soit cinq
par jour mais comment ce petit on se
passionne autant pour la cuisine alors
que pendant des années cuisiner tu cèdes
est avant tout une corvée vous savez
l'une de ses tâches ménagères qui a
servi les femmes un peu comme la lessive
le ménage et le repassage
du coup passé son temps en cuisine pas
s'était pas franchement valorisant
heureusement pour se libérer de cette
corvée qu'on pouvait compter sur la
science et le progrès mais bon le robot
ménager qu'on offre à la fête des mères
ne fait pas vraiment le sale boulot tout
seul du coup pour vraiment en finir avec
la cuisine au rêvait d'un futur où
l'homme se nourrirait de petites pilules
heureusement maintenant yapi l'espère
vous appuyez et deux minutes après vous
passer à table plus la peine de perdre
son temps à préparer les repas alors
c'est vrai que c'était pratique de
laisser la corvée de cuisine aux
industriels de l'agroalimentaire
n'empêche on a fini par se demander si
c'était vraiment une bonne idée d'avaler
de la bouffe en tube en boîte ou en
sachets sans vraiment savoir ce qu'on
mange ni quels produits chimiques a été
ajouté et c'est peut-être à ce moment là
on s'est dit que ce n'était pas si bête
de cuisiner soi-même
d'athor ont un peu de temps mais au
moins on sait ce qu'on a dans son
assiette et puis avec la crise on s'est
aussi rendu compte que cuisiner soi-même
ben saad et moins cher
bon appétit avant cuisiner c'est être
une corvée mais ça c'était avant en
quelques années tout a changé
aujourd'hui
cuisiner n'est plus une simple tâche
ménagère c'est devenu de l'art culinaire
la preuve les cuisiniers sont des stars
comme les chanteurs et les acteurs avant
on rêvait de devenir une vedette en
chantant sous sa douche et bain
aujourd'hui on peut éplucher des patates
dans cette cuisine et se prendre pour un
artiste
voilà c'était l'édito de blacko mise en
image de julia grappin ont bien raison
bonsoir
et journaliste gastronomique vous
collaborez notamment à l'express et
france inter bienvenue parmi nous merci
si votre adversaire rien oui c'est la
fin du monde est mon anniversaire j'ai
survécu aux deux
[Applaudissements]
on constate actuellement un
extraordinaire engouement pour la
cuisine des émissions des magazines des
livres des sites et aujourd'hui la
corvée de bouffe est devenu l'art
culinaire et la gastronomie française
est classé au patrimoine de l'humanité
par l'unesco voilà alors pourquoi
pourquoi mais je trouve que par rapport
à l'édito de blacko ce qui a changé
c'est pas tant que la cuisine n'est plus
une corvée passe comme on a vu la
cuisine quand on a trois enfants ont du
boulot à pas d'heure la cuisine c'est
une corvée et ça restera toujours une
corvée quand on n'a pas le temps ce qui
a changé c'est qu'à cuisiner plus
ringarde et qu'un chef n'est plus
ringard mais c'est ça qui en dix ans une
petite dizaine d'années a changé à la
faveur de mouvements qui ont décidé au
moment de déringardiser le chef de le
faire sortir de sa cuisine ont quitté
marmite en cuivre on quitte le col blanc
bleu blanc rouge le chef il n'est pas
forcément ses personnages bedonnant
confiné à faire des fonds de sauce il
devient un personnage m'a assez cool qui
est relancé la partie salut les terriens
tout le monde chante ses louanges un
gamin de 15 ans aujourd'hui il peut
rêver d'être chef c'est vrai qu'avant
vous voulez pas être mérité
mais s'est vu des deux d'angleterre
salue les pays anglo saxons on a voulu
être un peu jamie oliver jamie oliver et
on en a eu en france depuis une dizaine
les frères les équivalents c'est une
figure tout à coup qui devient assez
désirable quoi c'est un peu une nouvelle
idole quoi le chef ben vous vous êtes
appelés dès fois à l'étranger pour faire
des plats nomme david guetta
des promotions sur l'appel des
promotions c'est vrai que ça arrive mais
attention c'est que le débat il est plus
franco-français mais maintenant il est
planétaire alors qu'aujourd'hui on est
en concurrence avec des chefs espagnols
des chefs italiens des chefs japonais
qui est aussi son étoile et tout ça fait
qu'aujourd'hui le débat il est plus
franco-français françois c'est vrai
qu'il ya un boom de la cuisine
absolument incroyable enfin moi je mens
pas très bien compris que j'ai toujours
adoré faire la cuisine j'ai toujours
adoré évidemment très près de la manche
et alors les ris de veau we thank envers
pourquoi c'est du boulot qu'il ya un
travail qui est très très longs en amont
avant de les faire et donc c'est vrai
qu'il ya plein de choses mais j'aime
beaucoup de la cuisine chinoise c'est
très très long et fastidieux c2c ça peut
être une journée de travail sur pour
faire un carnage là qu'est par exemple
c'est moi j'adore faire ça ma mère m'a
initié à la cuisine très tôt mais c'est
dû à quoi ah nostalgie d'une époque où
on mangeait bien est-ce qu'une volonté
de transmission parce que c'est vrai que
les les parents soixante huitard ont pas
tellement communiqué la cuisine on se
retrouve avec des générations de filles
aujourd'hui que ça peut faire la cuisine
en fait la société chance ce mode ici la
cuisine suite derrière c'est la cuisine
loisirs est rien or aucune usine
ensemble recuit nos familles ont reculé
il ya un grand succès ce qui s'appelle
la fête des voisins est finalement c'est
plus la fête de la cuisine que la fête
des voisins partagent à paquets de pâtes
on se regroupe et en temps on a eu un
vingtième siècle une scène xxème siècle
tellement numérisés tellement chacun
pour soi tellement tellement d'enjeux ne
m'occupe pas de l'autre eh bien on a
besoin qu'on ne sait jamais de quoi on a
envie de partage de gastronomie et de
partage il n'y a pas de cuisine et
légitime non aujourd'hui les publics se
retrouvent dans toutes les cuisines mais
c'est vraiment pour moi aujourd'hui
l'avènement de la cuisine loisirs ce qui
était le cas aux états unis et aurait en
angleterre où il ya bien plus
d'émissions qu'en france c'est mondiale
même en chine la bad top chef s'appelle
30 millions d'amis
moi ce que je constate
et ça c'est étonnant dans cette émission
de cuisine et bien à chaque fois les
gens vont s'acheter ce qu'on a évoqué
par une émission la dernière mandoline à
la mode le dernier petit couteau à la
mode eh bien ils vont aller chez le même
fournisseur que vous pour vous pour
s'équiper servant de la cuisine devient
pas une obsession quand même depuis 10
ans oui mais en même temps c'est
finalement peu cher et rassurant on a
une société qui lie à travers ses 40
années où on a eu peur de tout perdre
son boulot d'avoir du boulot de ne pas
pouvoir le conserver et c on a vécu dans
la peur et initiés bien quelque chose
qui rassure qui rassemble c'est la
cuisine ouais on va regarder cette
cuisine de rue qui ciment sip aussi
maintenant on voit ces jeunes chefs
notamment à londres qui n'ont pas les
moyens de se sédentariser dans un lieu
en particulier qui ouvre un corner et
qui commence comme ça leur carrière 2003
qu'il ya aujourd'hui un public pour la
cuisine parce que la cuisine c'est
rassurant les gens ont peur de manquer
peut-être c'est ça l'explication lent et
je crois qu'ils ont envie de se
rapprocher moi je vois il ya un truc qui
me frappe toujours dans les cours de
cuisine que vous donnez à des adultes
ces deux cas passé les gens à
communiquer quand ils font la cuisine
ensemble alors à tous deux mille amis
sur facebook ne sait pas à qui prendre
un café le matin et ça va problème et
quand vous faites un cours de cuisine
que les adultes qui ne se connaissent
pas qui ne se sont jamais vus vraiment
ils finissent par communiqué un tel
point que les gens signent ici le client
signe ici tellement à la cuisine bien
souvent évolué mais vous n'avez pas mes
pattes et qu'une seule manière j'ai pris
15 cours de cuisine chez le chef je sais
faire alors maintenant prouver mon autre
chose avec la cuisine a poussé on
intervenait des petites cuisines et la
grande salle à manger maintenant là la
salle à manger a muté à aller au salon
et la cuisine est rentré dans ce cas
maintenant repli finalement un repli
identitaire parce qu'elle soit on est
difficile bien sûr il a lyon c'est sont
pas les deux armées dans la sono
mondiale alors aimer ses études pour
l'avenir mais bien dans la cuisine c'est
un refuge en même temps à ses hypers
valorisant c'est effectivement savoir
bien cuisine aujourd'hui c'est devenu
une vraie valeur ajoutée pour quiconque
puisse est assez accessible est assez
facile je fais des poissons fromages ça
te dit
c'est des bateaux du coup hier matin mon
image un peu de musique
lala tu fais la cuisine toi on va
m'accuser une arménienne s'est pas oui
mais ça c'est non dis pas ça à ma grand
mère barbara
c'est
ce qu'ils le base ball matt je connais
pas la bastonnade c'est un souci sont
assez forts faut pas trop à manger sinon
tu deviens aveugle mais merde non non
non le sous deux jours le bellec
je suis sur le switch le boulet que le
nom c'est le benêt qu on voulait que ça
veut dire [ __ ] mais
bonnec le bellec c'est délicieux le riz
pilaf tu connais alors épitaphe pour toi
c'est remanié le riz pilaf fermer ni
arabes est d'accord il ya aussi quelques
arméniens les sushis arménien
ha tard tout est arménienne toute armée
on a tous nous quand je fais pas la
cuisine je sais pas je suis pas très bon
je crois pas que 2 replis identitaires
je peux rentrer à la cuisine si c'est
bien une chose qu'elle a si elle a bien
une force c'est d'être ouverte à tous
les vents il n'y a pas d'identité en
cuisine et des terroirs enfin elle est
ouverte à tous les mondes quoi s'il y
aura pas une tomate en france rappelle
jours plus tôt qu'exporter il préfère
faire de la cuisine c'est plus facile
quand même temps oui mais c'est pas un
repli identitaire ces silos souterrains
sur le marché international la cuisine
française et l'hôtellerie française
seront bien sûr marché national
aujourd'hui c'est quand même des devises
qui nous rendre grâce à la gastronomie
en général quand je mets ya même des
cours de cuisine à la fois j'étais au
printemps tu as des rayons de fringues
et dans un endroit des gens qui
apprennent à faire la cuisine ont
volontairement je pense qu'à un cours de
cuisine tous contre un jour jacques
bizard
là c'est la question oui on toujours
c'est le réveillon qu'est-ce qu'on a
échappé à la fin du monde
tu vas manger alors moi chaque année je
vois mes grands parents ce que je pense
que c'est pour le testament tout ça et
on ne sait jamais c'est peut-être la
dernière année j'arrive avec mon
testament un crayon et une gomme et non
non on fait des gros repas arménien quoi
du boulet
des sushis non non j'ai bien chez moi
sans délai c'est bien ouais donc là tu
vas manger quoi pour vous avez un chez
moi ils sont mon père est arménien et ma
mère est normal alors dû qu'aux
dernières côté arménien ça sera un beauf
arménienne et du côté c'est provençal
donc ça sera dur ce duo marc nexon comme
ça sympa qu'est ce tu vas manger tu vois
pas le rêve et surtout pas de date parce
que ça et surtout pas de biche parce que
je repousse donc ce sera certainement 18
hrs voilà des huîtres et du foie gras et
du foie gras vous mais ouais et puis du
croisic et puis du poulet ou lever des
liquidités
alors elle vira classique c'est pas très
rigolo chapon way boudin blanc truffé
pas mal non
des huîtres saumon fumé du nom du juge
nit saumon fumé foie gras non comment
cette évidente à oui d'accord ma mère va
faire une espèce de tourte aux pommes
la pâte feuilletée des épices c'est très
franco-français quand même un
malin peut elle est un peu anglais sur
les bords et thierry faisait manger quoi
vous pour le réveillon est simple c'est
je suis un peu comme ça aussi 18 on a un
peu de poisson cru en entrée et en plat
ont fait 1
un classique de la cuisine française
pour salindres anglais c'est le filet de
boeuf wellington c'était un plat
d'auguste escoffier en 1907 au savon y
c'est un filet de boeuf juste rôti comme
ça vous le passez avec une peur et une
duxelle de champignons danny flynn purée
de champignons et vous le voulez dans
une pâte feuilletée vêtements rétro ça
pour ça séraphine les pâtons fromage
c'est quoi le meilleur truc si jamais
mangé de votre vie il ya un produit qui
me laisse toujours un très grand
souvenir parce que il est bourré de
paradoxes c'est le fugu japonais parce
que c'est pia pas de goût c'est la
texture qui était à nantes en bouche et
ça c'est quelque chose je me sens qu'ils
peuvent vous tuer si oui mais bon il ya
ces impressions très dangereux pour
elles un bon s'il est battu est lui-même
un souci est assez simple c'est un
poisson qui dévisse hier dans lequel les
contenus un poison mortel
qui attaque le système nerveux mais bon
il ya une formation les gens qui vous
prépare ça mais c'est très très bon
c'est pas très bon a versé c'est surtout
la posture qui m'a indiscutable au bâton
fromage c'est moins dangereux
merci
merci d'avoir été avec nous voilà il
faut être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu